Is
it just me or are more people allergic to
peanuts now than ever before?
What's going on?
Why are we allergic to these little things?
Peanuts are delicious.
They're free on airplanes, and though I'm
not a huge fan of peanut butter unless it's
on a granny smith apple -- it's a very popular
thing in the US.
And yet, peanut allergies are becoming an
epidemic!
Or… maybe they're not, and we're just freaking
out.
Humans do that.
Firstly, there are two negative ways your
body can react to food.
Allergic reaction, or intolerance.
An intolerance is like indigestion, your body
isn't HAPPY with the food you've consumed,
but it's not dangerous.
The VAST majority of people who react to peanuts
and other foods have intolerances.
If you can eat a peanut accidentally and not
die, but you won't feel great, you probably
are intolerant, not allergic.
The FDA says 90 percent of all food allergies
are caused by milk or dairy, eggs, certain
fish and shellfish, wheat, soybeans, tree
nuts and peanuts.
If you accidentally eat even a tiny bit of
these and are allergic, you'd have a severe
and rapid reaction.
Allergies are your immune system freaking
out and attacking what it thinks is a pathogen.
Though food allergies are a growing problem,
only 8-percent of children have them, and
of those less than 40 percent react severely.
According to a 2010 study by Mount Sinai Hospital,
only 1.4 percent of children were allergic
to peanuts specifically, and other numbers
are even lower.
Pollen, by contrast, affects as many as 1
in 5 people according to The Asthma and Allergy
Foundation!
But, of course, pollen doesn't cause anaphylaxis
-- or a potentially fatal immune reaction
that can be so strong it inhibits breathing.
The CDC, though, says deaths are rare -- only
17 people from 1979 to 1995 -- way fewer than
died from lightning strikes.
That being said, we ARE getting more allergic
to things.
It's growing.
The number of people allergic to peanuts has
tripled since the late 70s, and scientists
don't know why…
Even still, they're working on solutions.
A 2014 study in the journal JAMA Pediatric
found if moms consumed peanuts while pregnant,
the kid in the womb had a much lower risk
of developing the peanut allergy!
Perhaps part of the rise is because moms are
eating fewer peanuts?
Scientists figure the early exposure to tiny
levels of peanut proteins will help prep the
developing fetus so they don't freak out when
they meet them on the outside.
But again, they aren't sure.
Since we know the allergic population is growing,
there are lots of steps being taken to protect
kids.
A University of Florida study this week found
pulsing UV light onto peanuts eroded an allergen
protein called "ARA h1-h3" to a QUOTE "undetectable
level."
A University of Florida study this week found
pulsing UV light onto peanuts eroded the allergen
proteins ARA h1, h2 and h3 to a QUOTE "undetectable
level."
According to the report, they can cut the
allergens so 95 percent of people with allergies
would be safe!
It might be extreme, but it could mean a lot
for the piece of mind at school cafeterias.
In the end, kids CAN and often DO grow out
of their youthful allergies.
There ARE schools that have banned peanut
butter -- much to the chagrin American Academy
of Allergy, Asthma and Immunology, The Food
Allergy & Anaphylaxis Network and other parents.
They all agree, bans aren't the answer.
It's better to treat each child with their
individual allergy symptoms, as those symptoms
arise.
Are you allergic to peanuts or intolerant?
What do you think is causing all these allergies?!